okay my name is Martin Sorrell CEO WB
and the session that we have was on
national brand so if I'm asked to
summarize it in as signature specialist
problem is very difficult which we went
on for that our a quarter i would say
that what we underlying yet again was
the importance of national branding on a
world scale if we're in the advertising
and marketing services business and i
would say that it's a result of our
session i'm firmly if you even further
that when i went into the social graph
that national branding government
branding city bragging branding is going
to become more and more important
overcoming it if you think about how the
world is organized with fifty percent of
the world's population now in the cities
and shortly seventy percent of the world
is managing cities managing competition
between cities in terms of location of
industries of services so primary
secondary and tertiary industries is
critically important to growth and
development so how governments wrestle
with these issues how they brand just
like companies do just like products and
services do critically important but the
real issue is how you doing in train way
often when you have national branding
done through governments the prime
minister the president the Ministry of
Trade of Industry Minister of investment
the Minister of Tourism will all have
conflicting views about the allocation
of resources have the integration of
resources so it's the old old issues of
strategy instruction clearly countries
have to develop a strategy obviously
branding around that strategy and then
they have to implement them in effective
ways so country branding natural
branding is a critical issue and a more
and more important issue the
government's
people and companies because business
has a big role to play in this as well
have to wrestle in and grab so this is
front and center of the agenda
government's